los niños rescatados del guaviare con
buena salud después de estar más de un
mes en la selva Virgen del guaviare los
cuatro hermanos mucutuí se encontraban
exhaustos y con signos de desnutrición
visible sin embargo tras tres días
internados en el hospital Militar de
Bogotá el ministro de salud colombiano
confirma que los pequeños se encuentran
estables y con buena salud y quiero
darle un parto a todos los colombianos
de la buena salud que tienen hoy
nuestros niños y especialmente la forma
como ha sido tratado y atendido por
parte de esta gran institución los
equipos de rescate hicieron uso de
altavoces helicópteros con cámaras de
calor y grandes reflectores para
iluminar la noche en la espesa selva sin
embargo el protagonista del rescate fue
Wilson un perro rescatista que fue vital
para que los cuerpos de búsqueda dieran
con el paradero de los niños las huellas
de Wilson guiaron a los rescatistas
hacia los menores pero el perro ya no
estaba con Los Hermanos la ubicación de
Wilson es desconocida aún pero el
ejército expresó que no pararán las
operaciones en la selva hasta
encontrarlo bueno la operación Esperanza
continúa
de acuerdo a los lineamientos del señor
presidente señor ministro de la defensa
nacional esta operación culmina Dios
mediante con la ayuda de él Hasta que
logremos recuperar al canino Wilson en
este momento tenemos en esta área de
operaciones
setenta comandos de la fuerzas militares
en la búsqueda y en la recuperación del
canino las niñas fueron rescatados del
Amazonas colombiano el pasado 9 de junio
por un equipo de rescate conformado por
el ejército nacional y las comunidades
indígenas locales un hito histórico que
ha traído felicidad a los hogares en
Colombia